hello there and welcome to this episode
of the slow mo guys on YouTube I think
we should call it a slinky guys first
this is the slinky guys I saw a cool
video on YouTube once of some sciency
people demonstrating how when you drop a
slinky it like collapses onto the last
ring and then it all falls at the same
time instead of falling as one unit like
that
and it's pretty cool that a little bit
of slow-mo but we thought we'd go full
slo-mo on it and a scene this is about
no mr. battle slow-mo get on the go
alright so we're going to drop them at
the same time you shouldn't see this
stay pretty still and let's just
collapse onto the top of that report
four three two one drop
cool
do you know anything about the slinky
down happens I do yeah it was invented
by Edgar f slinky correct in 1963 I
believe yeah that was actually his
second project which he started after he
invented the snake yeah in a 1917 yeah
yes I the slinky was his more a
successful product but he was more proud
of the snake I believe it's true you may
find this video to be less informative
than the other slinky video yeah we do
more slow more less info we do it equal
info just it's kind of it's true